- All right, so Raymond.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Raymond where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- I grew up in Los Angeles, Watts.
You know all my life,
basically until I went
to the Youth Authority at the age of 12,
you know and then, at the age of 12,
I actually lost my moms, though, too.
I was 12 years old.
And, I lost my mom when I
was in the Youth Authority
and at that point I
think I just lost it all.
Because, losing her was like
the only thing I had, you know?
And when she passed, it
took everything from me.
And so, I ended up doing
five and a half years
in the Youth Authority.
So, I mean I tore up
everything because of the pain.
I couldn't, had nobody to talk to,
nobody to confide in and--
- So, Youth Authority is what?
It's for?
- California Youth Authority,
it's for the youth.
Like, from 12 to 17.
- [Mark] Who ends up there?
- People who commit crimes, like kids.
- [Mark] Yeah, so what was your crime?
- Robbery, GTA.
Yeah.
All right?
- Yeah.
- I got caught the same day.
Same fucking, (laughs)
same half hour.
- In the same hour.
You stole a car?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I, see that's what I mean,
I didn't have the guidance in my house.
There was, my father was a drug addict,
my mother was an alcoholic.
And in that sense,
there was nobody to
control me or to help me.
So, I followed the
footsteps of everybody else
that was in the street.
I was looking for something,
and I ran to the streets.
And, (sighs) nobody ever told me
that the streets would
take me under, you know?
I was a kid like, like,
and so, I did what they did,
looking for a big brother,
a father figure, looking
for some kind of family.
And, that wasn't there.
So, I was in the streets,
I've been in the streets all my life.
Like, I'm still in the
streets and it's crazy
because the streets
brung me to using drugs
and it's crazy because
like the drugs like,
I never, like looking back,
I never woulda expected my life to be
in a shit hole like,
it's a real fuck,
it's a real fucking shit hole like,
I used crystal meth, crack cocaine, PCP.
I been out here like,
you know, and thinking that was cool.
It was the only way I had
and so, even when you know the way is bad,
it's the only way you have
in this, fuck it, it's
like fuck it, you know?
I do what I got to do
and like all I was doing
was chasing my tail.
All I was doing was chasing my tail.
It's fucking amazing.
You know, I've been out, everybody knows,
everybody, your boy know,
everybody knows me because
when I was out here it
was go to work get it.
I don't give a damn how I got to get it,
I'm fittin' to lie to you.
I'm fittin' to tell
you this big old story.
Hey look check this out,
my boy he got this, he got this,
you would give me your money.
I would take your money
I would have fake dope in my pocket,
I would say I'll be right back.
I would run around the corner,
would take the fake dope out my pocket
buy the real dope, watch
you smoke this fake dope.
Oh man, he got us.
I would leave with the
real dope in my pocket.
That's scheming, I was a schemer
like any means necessary.
I didn't give a fuck, just smoke it.
That's your dope.
But it was to feed my habit.
It was like like that monster like,
that monster was a motherfucker.
That monster is motherfucker.
And, I guess to this day,
I'm still dealing with
that monster, you know?
Because I try, I think like,
"okay, not today", you know?
Not today, not today,
but it could be any day.
You know?
I'm an addict.
I'm a recovering addict if
that's what you want to call it.
But, I think I'd call it a process
because I'm still going
through the shit out here.
I'm still out here.
You know, I'm still out here
and I think it's hope,
it's faith, it's this right here,
this key around my neck,
it says faith.
And that's the key right
there, that's the key man.
That's the key.
The key is faith.
Even though I'm still in this bond.
This tight rope around my neck,
I believe that
I believe I can make it like,
I ain't made it yet
but I believe that if I
keep doing what I'm doing,
and stay focused, I'm you know,
trying to stay focused out here is crazy,
because I still look back
on the things that I lost
and I still look back.
It's still, I don't know
how I still carry this on.
I don't know why I still carry this on.
(sighs) I don't know why I do
but there's some things
you can't let go of,
like us, me as a person,
I don't know why I hold on to things.
You know what I'm saying?
I hold onto shit
that's hard to let go and I think I do it
because the trauma it put me through.
You know what I'm saying?
The situation, the shit
that I went through
in these episodes kind of like,
you can't let this go.
I can't let this go.
Because it hurts so much.
It's like a scar, you
know how you got a scar?
And you can still look at your arm
or your body and still see that scar
and the reflection of that
scar like how I got that scar.
That's sort of like the
things that hold on to,
you know what I'm saying?
The things I hold on to, I
got a daughter I haven't seen
in years because of my
life in the streets.
You know what I'm saying?
My life in the streets,
my daughter's about to be 14.
- [Mark] Did you raise her?
- No, I've been in prison, you know?
And every time I got out of prison,
I went back to prison,
because I remember this,
I used to sit up in prison
right before I got out,
and say, "yeah, I fittin'
to go get a quarter piece,
"I'm fittin' get some dope,
"I'm fittin' to hit these street"
and da da da da da (hands clap).
Right off to the race.
I never thought about my daughter.
I never thought about her.
I never thought about her well being,
I never thought about,
"she need a father".
I never thought about that.
And she's fittin' to be 14.
And it's amazing that,
you know, I changed but I
feel like it's too late.
You know, as a father, it's too late,
I mean, you got a chance to make some,
I ain't have a chance
to make some things up
and get some things right.
But then again I look at,
you can't make nothing
up, you can't fix what's,
you can't fix what's broken,
you'll just take these pieces
and put them together
and work with 'em, like,
and, you know, my baby mama, she got,
I believe she have a reason
for some of the things she do.
Like keeping my daughter
at a distance, you know?
Keeping her at a distance,
but it's not fair to me at this point.
Being that I changed but
nobody will see your change.
Nobody will see the process
you go through to change.
Nobody sees that,
all they see is you, this you,
you know, he goes to jail.
He's in and out of prison.
You know, he can't stop
selling drugs, using drugs,
he can't stop.
People put that he can't stop on me
and I think it's my fault.
It's my fault.
And so, that goes back to what
I was saying about that scar.
My fault, you know what I'm saying?
Every time I look at it
and it's, it fucks me up
but I mean mentally it fucks me up
because I have to deal with it, you know?
I wish, I mean there's
so many things I wish,
I wish I could take back, you know?
I wish I, but you can't change
what's already out there.
Like, you know?
Every day I get up
and fight not to go back to me,
you know what I'm saying?
Every day I get up and you
know I want to you know,
Money, money, money.
That seems like it makes
everybody happy, money, shit.
So now I'm learning like money is not it,
it's not the material things
that satisfies people.
I mean, these are only
temporary things that,
this money, temporary don't satisfy you.
At the end of the day, when
the money's gone, then what?
So I think like that.
But then it's like shit,
you need that money.
You need that,
because that money
satisfies everybody else.
And it seems like we trying to,
we as people try to satisfy every,
'cause we need people, you know?
We need people and it's like,
fuck how far am I willing to
go to satisfy someone else?
When you look at it, that's why
I say money's not important.
That's another part of this
is that money, it's not,
it's not what you need, you know?
What you need is compassion.
You know, what you need is understanding,
what you need is somebody
that can talk to you.
You could talk to without all the agendas,
no hidden agendas, you know?
I'm only fucking with you
because you got some money.
Or, I'm only fucking with you
because you get some money.
I see a lot of that, a
lot of that, you know?
- [Mark] How many years you
been down here on Skid Row?
- Shit, just 2000, 20 years,
I been down here 20 years.
Been down here 20 years,
sleeping in tents,
sidewalks, fuck without a tent,
you know what I'm saying?
- Mm-hmm.
- I would fucking run to
any one of these spots
with all these clothes and
see a bunch of bums out,
I fittin' asleep right here.
I'm gonna fall asleep
right here on the street.
That mentality, I mean,
when I look back at that shit,
I'm like "wow, I can't
believe how I lost myself."
But then I can, I can because
being a realist I say that
because of the drugs and the chasing
that I did was the distractions.
All these was distractions
from me being focused on doing something.
But I think that these
distractions were put there
for me to see that they
were distractions, you know?
I mean, I lost everything.
I lost everything like you know,
I have no relationship with anyone.
I mean, my family stays in Fontana,
San Bernardino and all that
and here I am stuck in LA with no support.
I am my only support system.
- [Mark] When was the last
time you saw your family?
- (whistles) Shit,
early 2000, 2012 or some shit like that.
It's been a while.
It's been a while,
I got nieces and nephews
I haven't even seen.
I got cousins that I
don't even know, you know?
I get on Facebook now and I meet people,
I don't even know who they is
but they related to me somehow some way
and it fucks me up
because you family and I don't
even know that, you know?
- [Mark] What do you think it
is that keeps you down here?
- What keeps me down here?
(laughs) What keeps,
actually, I'm gonna say I love down here
because of the the shit that
I went through, you know?
And all the trouble that I went through,
it started down here and so,
I figure "why, why leave here,
"when you become better as a person,
"you can leave"
but it's this right here that made me,
you know what I'm saying?
It's all these scars down
here that keep me down here
it's all the scars,
it's all the scars down
here that keep me down here,
I can't get rid of these scars.
- [Mark] You feel like you belong here?
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, I mean,
this is (sighs) it's Skid Row,
downtown Skid Row, man, shit.
I mean, you can get robbed,
you can get killed.
Anything can happen down here.
And why do I still put
myself in that situation?
I guess because it doesn't
bother me, you know?
It would bother someone else
to come down here and look at this shit
and be like "man, what the fuck?"
It would bother somebody,
it's a lot of people that
don't even come down here
because of this.
- They avoid it.
- But when you look at this,
if you actually get a
chance to look at this,
you'll see that it's not,
it's not that bad, it's not
the place it's the people.
And, that's just what it is and,
and if it's the people,
then the people got to
change not the place.
You can't change the place,
it's the people that gotta change.
And I'm one of those
persons, one of those people
that actually had the
chance to see that like,
you can't keep doing the
same shit, over and over.
You can't keep doing, like I said,
I used to sit up in prison,
say "yeah, I'ma get out, sell this dope,
"I'm gonna do this, this."
But when I opened my eyes,
I was right there in a jail cell,
I was still laying on that bunk.
And that part of reality hit
me like, "you son of a bitch,
"you son of a bitch.
"So you gonna keep doing this?"
And when I say this, I
mean coming back to prison.
"You gonna keep doing this?
"Keep doing it and you'll
keep getting the same shit."
It's hard.
It's very hard to change.
Change is hard.
Because most people don't want to change.
We are comfortable.
I'm comfortable in this shit.
And that's just what it is, shit.
I'm comfortable in it.
That's the crazy part about it.
When you realize, when you sit back
and you start to see
this shit for what it is,
I'm comfortable in this shit?
That's insanity.
Okay, how did you get to insanity?
How did you get to this point?
I got to this point because I got lost.
I got lost, I got distracted.
(laughs) I got distracted
but I allowed myself to be distracted.
And it's amazing,
how you slip in this shit like,
if you not ready for the game,
don't step in the game, period.
Don't, if you got family
and shit that love you
and stick with that, I
mean, first, people like,
you got to realize you
got to love yourself.
There is nobody that's gonna
love you greater than you.
And we forget that.
We forget that because
we get so distracted
in what we got going on.
I need some company,
all company ain't good
company, all company,
I'm still learning that, all
company ain't good company.
There's people out here that,
I'll be waiting and I'll
be like, "damn you loud.
"You hella just just respect, you just,
"you're not my cup of tea."
Now I'm starting to see that
it's the cup and the tea man.
It's what you put you,
if I hang around bullshit, then
I'm gonna attract bullshit,
even though I don't do the bullshit,
all the bullshit I hang
around will surround me.
All the bullshit I hang
I'm still here like, it's a
story that I want to tell.
Because it's a story
that somebody has to hear
like my story could help somebody else.
Take some pieces from this story
and put it in and put it in your story
so you don't make the
same mistakes I've made.
I've been in the streets my whole life
like gang banging and all that
like all of it was a
part of the destruction.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, really fucking, like,
I'm 40 years old, I'm about to be 41
and I have 20, from 12
to fuck what's that?
20 something years?
And I've been down here 20 years.
So you can see the fall,
you can see the shit, man.
You can see all the years I lost.
And I can see all the years I lost.
And so I step on that, I use
that as a stepping stone,
you know what I'm saying?
And I use it as a stepping
stone to help somebody else out.
Because to me, that's what life is about,
like, even in a situation what they say?
"It's not where you at,
"It's about what you about.
"It's about you" and I know now
that see, either you can be a builder,
or you can be a destroyer.
You can help somebody up or
you can pull somebody down.
That's either, that's either,
that's only two things
you gonna do in life.
But you make that choice.
You make that choice,
and it goes back to the choice I made.
That's what I look way
back to the choices I made,
to the choices I made, way back, god damn.
It's my, it's heavy on the mind
because I want to say I
lost but I didn't lose.
You know?
You know, it take a loss,
sometimes it takes a loss
for you to gain something.
Sometimes you got to
lose this to get to this
and (sighs) no matter what, like,
who's to know what's gonna happen next?
I'm still on parole.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm still on parole going
through the shit I'm going through.
And I'm still trying to make it like,
but I probably wouldn't have the heart
or the courage to make it,
do you understand that?
if I wasn't down here,
if it wasn't for rock bottom,
I'd probably never got up, you know,
I'd probably never got up
if it wasn't for this
shit right here, you know?
I know all the drug addicts.
I know all the dealers,
I know everybody.
But that don't mean I
have to be part of it.
I don't have to be part of it.
And that's by choice.
Like it's always the choice.
It's a choice.
It's a choice and
looking at those choices,
I also look at the
repercussion on the choices.
So you got to see in advance,
and that's why I'm telling my story,
because I hope my story helps somebody see
in advance, you know?
Tattoos, battles wounds,
all that shit, you know what I'm saying?
Still, I still have a
mentality where I go hard.
I have to go hard though.
I have to go hard.
Because I'm not given no passes.
I'm very serious about my recovery.
I'm very serious about
getting ahead in life.
And when I left all this shit alone,
that cut it off, you know?
That's how I am as a person.
When I make my mind up to do something,
that's it, I mean, 'cause I'm all I got.
I'm all I got, I don't, like I said,
you can have family members,
but support, support that's important.
- [Mark] How important do
you think not having a father
in your life was?
- Very, I mean my father was,
he couldn't give me
the support or the love
and shit that most kids have, you know?
And it was very important
because I needed a father figure,
I needed that man,
I needed that, you know?
Teach me and since I
didn't have that teach me,
I went to the streets and
the streets taught me.
And it's crazy, you know?
But I still talk to my pop's now.
I just talked to him yesterday.
We like this, we,
but I try to forgive, you know?
I forgive my father for
not understanding how
to be a father.
I forgive my father for, like
I said not understanding,
that he probably didn't have that
'cause he was in the streets, you know?
And so I look back and say,
"well, maybe he didn't
have that structure,
"that guidance to give to me."
And as, you're gonna always
love your father, your mother,
you're gonna always love your people.
And so, you know, it's very important
to have a father figure,
a parent figure, you know?
A solid foundation
and that's why i say I'm very serious
about what I'm serious about,
because I'm setting a foundation
and I refuse, I refuse to go backwards.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't know, there's
this story in the Bible
that says that, I forget
I think it was Lot,
where the prophecy came and
told them to leave the village
'cause we gonna burn this thing down.
We're fittin' to destroy this village
and the wife,
he told him "take your wife and your kids
"and get out", you know?
The wife was like, "No, no" but she left.
And when they went up the mountains,
when they got past these
hills and out of the village,
she looked back and she
turned into a pillar of salt.
So, that moral of that
story, it's more like
when you start moving
ahead, don't look back.
Don't look back, that's my thing.
Don't look back,
'cause she looked back and
she turned into a pillar salt,
for looking back,
when he told you to go
ahead, you looked back.
And that story in that Bible like,
that sticks to me, like,
'cause I can be that pillar
of salt for looking back.
I've been that, you know?
Over and over, 20 years, I
been down here 20 years, same,
I'm tired of being that pillar.
If I'm gonna be a pillar, I'm
gonna be a positive pillar,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm gonna be something you can stand on.
I'm gonna be something
you can take something from, you know?
That's just, I'm very
serious about this like,
like very serious about my recovery.
And when I say recovery,
I'm not just talking about as an addict.
I'm talking about as a person,
because you get so caught up
in this addiction out here,
this lifestyle that you lose everything.
Who want to be a loser (laughs)?
Who'd want to be a loser?
And so I think that I'm blessed
to be able to tell my story
and see it, I'm able to see it.
So I hope somebody else
will see it, you know?
I mean, I'm the type of person
that I'll help you with
whatever you need help with.
If I can help you, I'll help you
because that's what I feel life is about,
life is about helping
people now not the same.
"Well, you know, I got this"
and taking something from you.
That's the problem.
Sometimes you take so much,
you got two hands and your hands are full,
from taking, what do you have to give?
You can't give nothing
'cause done you took so much
that you so used to taking
that you can't give a hand out.
That's not, that's, you know,
for every man you come to a
point in life where it's like,
"fuck, I gotta start giving.
"I got to start giving."
To get you got to give, see?
'Cause if you'd never
give, you'll never get.
I promise you that.
If you never give you'll never get.
And fuck, it's crazy because
all the scars that I have,
and I'm still able to give
like, fuck, I'm able to,
I'm able to forgive.
I think that's like,
really forgiveness is the
biggest part of anything,
you got to forgive yourself first though.
You got to forgive yourself
'cause if you can't forgive you,
then you can't forgive
nobody else, you know?
It's like, people may have
played a part in the things
that caused you to be who you are.
But when you really
look back on that shit,
you could say, "okay, well,
"though this was a piece
"that I say that made me
do the shit that I did.
"Actually, I did it because I did it.
"I did it.
"You didn't make me do what I did.
"I did that" you know?
And so now, I just hope that life, like,
I know life, I don't hope
because I don't like to use hope like,
when you moving ahead in life,
and you're doing positive
shit, positive things happen.
I mean, you can't go wrong doing right.
You can't go wrong doing right.
And, you know, and I
heard about you, Mark.
So I wanted to come here and tell my story
because there's so many
people who need somebody
and for some kind of,
there's so many people
who need somebody else's story
to fix their story, you know?
And I just hope
that my story can help
somebody else fix their story.
- [Mark] I'm sure it can.
- Like I said, man, this key is faith,
it's faith, man.
And that's what I live by now.
I live by faith.
You know?
I live by faith like faith in me,
faith in doing positive, it's like,
it's just about faith.
I think faith brung me
to this day, you know?
But, it is what it is.
- [Mark] All right, Raymond.
Thank you so much for coming in.
- Yeah, thank you.
- Great.
- And God bless y'all.
- Thank you.